new law signed by President Trump
yesterday allows terminally ill patients
easier access to experimental drugs
eight-year-old jordan McGlynn celebrated
the long-awaited moment by hugging the
president that's a good hug jordan
jordan became the nationwide face of the
right to try campaign as he battles
Duchenne muscular dystrophy now we've
been following a story for years and
spoke to him and his mother after the
signing adriana dr diaz rather is here
with what they had to say
Adriana Diaz sorry didn't mean to mess
up your name good morning welcome to the
table good morning Gail King right to
try makes good on what a president
Trump's campaign promises but the bill
is not without controversy opponents
argue what's risky and doesn't give
better access to drugs but proponents
like eight-year-old Jordan and his mom
believe it could be life-saving
as president Trump signed the right to
try bill Wednesday eight year old Jordan
McLean went in for a hug he missed the
first few times but eventually they
embraced a hug years in the making
Jordan has Duchenne muscular dystrophy a
genetic generative disease with an
average life expectancy of around 25
years gonna see it just finally come to
the finish line was just this huge huge
accomplishment Jordan and his mother
Laura McLean have been at the forefront
of the movement to pass the right to try
bill which allows the terminally ill who
have exhausted all other options to gain
access to drugs not fully approved yet
by the FDA
we first met the McLean family in 2015
when write to try was signed into law in
their home state of Indiana by then
Governor Mike Pence he has been very
very supportive all along the way under
FDA regulations new drugs must go
through three phases of clinical trials
before becoming commercially available
which often takes years right to try now
allows doctors to administer drugs that
have cleared just the first phase of a
trial we're gonna be saving tremendous
numbers of lives but opponents of right
to try argue so-called compassionate use
treatments already allow patients to try
experimental drugs
the FDA currently approves about 99% of
experimental drug requests
unfortunately it's empty symbolism
Allison Bateman house and is
professor of medical ethics fears the
bill gives false hope nobody can force a
company to give a drug if it doesn't
want to I am NOT optimistic that it is
going to be a pathway of getting access
for patients but Laura McLin is still
hopeful we've met so many people from
different disease groups that can
benefit from this law I had that head of
hair I would have been president so long
ago as for Jordan he had a long day but
meeting the president was worth it he
said my hair was very nice he then Laura
McLean said Jordan's actually now in the
65th week of a clinical trial
she said they continued the right to try
fight for others she told me this
morning that people with his condition
can eventually lose the ability to hug
as you saw he is a hugger ya said that
she's going to do whatever she can to
make sure he could keep on hugging and
he waited for the hug to that's what was
so sweet and tried to go and go and then
he said I'll just sit here and wait I
love that when you tried to play it off
he was like no no I'm just here hanging
little kids do the president was right
he does have a great head of hair but
I'll be he's got a lot more going for
him yes he does updated this story yeah
there's a special little boy thank you
Adriana thank you